foreign
you do not have to learn all of life's
lessons the hard way
you can choose to watch other people be
idiots and not do what they did
so I could be the sample idiot that
doesn't have to so you don't have to go
buy a bunch of nothing down real estate
and then George can live a proper life
and you know buy his first house very
conservatively sell it buy another house
pay it off and uh by 32 be a millionaire
with zero debt and never had you don't
have to you don't have to go through
drug rehab to have a testimony to decide
to not do drugs
me I have to do everything the hard way
but you guys can learn from me because I
have a PhD in Dumb and you did it very
publicly Dave most people do it in
private you chose to broadcast it it's
worse than that I made it into a brand
I made my stupidity into a brand is that
the guy involved for bankruptcy
bankruptcy and tells people how to get
out of debt what kind of dumb butt is
that well one that knows the track
record but knows what it's like you know
I mean one that's touched the hot stove
that's trying to warn others I can just
you know I can you don't have to teach
get grab your kid's hand put it up there
you know you just don't don't touch it I
did it once it's not good for you well I
think the heart of it is people are
feeling desperate with the economy and
inflation I'll never build wealth and so
they start taking shortcuts and fear
greed and pride kick in a little bit and
all of a sudden they make some risky
decisions and the risk meter gets broken
or they put it aside and decide I'm
gonna be the exception to the rule I
know what Dave says but I saw it work
out on a guy on Tick Tock so therefore
it's gonna work out for me yeah it's um
I suck other day cities
his uh 11 year old had a um
oh God he had this whole thing that was
completely illegal built out oh wow well
I mean he was funding Roth IRAs and they
didn't have any earned income oh I've
seen this one yeah and it's some kind of
like tax hack and you can give your kids
income my four-year-old works for me
full time and I pay them sixty thousand
dollars a year and they're and I'm
funding uh uh that's illegal the IRS is
about to be on your butt yeah when you
get audited you will have like the
capital L on your forehead thing that
says Loser yeah that's what will happen
oh my God you
got you so no you you hit you hit it
though it's the traffic uh and I have
done all three uh and all three will
make you broke greed
fear and pride
see pride is I buy a car to impress
someone at a stoplight that I will never
meet
it's like a Christmas Vacation good
looking girl waving at Chevy Chase and
he wrecks his whole family's car right
it's that that's your deal you remember
that oh that's such a great it's a
classic scene was it Christy Brinkley I
think so I think so I rewatched it
recently yeah the audience has given me
a a nod so that a trivial Pursuits got
it okay the uh uh and so that that's
Pride you know and I've done that one
when you buy crap and Rachel's thing she
posted and you've talked you wrote about
it in your new book that we haven't oh
we haven't told anything about the
secret I just finished the master the
manuscript last weekend's really good
but the uh she talked about in that she
said if would I buy this if no one ever
saw it oh yeah that's your test on the
pride button right it's a gut check the
word the greed greed is not like
it's not like you know Simon Legree and
Scrooge Scrooge McDuck and I'm stacking
coins in the cave
that's not greed
greed is I'm just Money Motivated to the
exclusion of other things that are
healthy
you can have a money motivation and not
and not being excluded to the exclusion
of other things but if your own if
you're only button to push is money
that's great and you're always going to
step in
the do when you do that and the third
one I love you said is desperate that's
the worst one God that one right there
man I the other two I got over the other
two by the time I was like 27 28 years
old that that desperate one that will
really come that's when people you know
I'm gonna take the trip to Vegas and
I'll hit and that'll save my business
that's you know when you get desperate
just about 20 seconds later after I get
desperate I get stupid and right after I
get stupid I get broke right I mean it's
true that's an aggressive causal thing
it desperate leads to stupid leads to
broke when you go oh I've got it's the
only way it's my only that you're about
to screw up when you get in your drama
queen gets to kicking in you're about to
screw up but they heard that one story
of that guy who went to Vegas and it was
on the line and he did it and he doubled
his money and said and saved and save
the business yeah I've read a couple of
business books where the guy says you
know if I was down I couldn't make
payroll on Friday so I went to Vegas on
Wednesday and I made payroll and now I'm
such and such I've heard that I don't
know if they're true but I you know they
make for a great reason let me just tell
you it's not a good business it's not
business practice it's not life practice
it's not a life hack it's just straight
up stupidity that somebody got away with
you know well somebody's got to win the
house wins brother the house wins look
at the side look at the quality of their
furniture and light fixtures better than
yours okay the house wins they have more
lights and dinghies than you do there's
a reason they took your money and they
took fools like yours money before you
got there that's how they got that the
house wins sports betting is hilarious
people that don't understand statistics
Sports bet that have you never had a
class in statistics if you took a class
in statistics you'd understand where the
bookie wins you understand why people
there's how they pay for duber with the
gold necklace that was a Caesars oh yeah
the Caesars commercials that guy man how
do you pay that guy and you pay all that
production and you know what their what
their budget is for a jillion dollars
for seizures for sports betting and
where do they get the money for that you
America oh hello you thinking you're
gonna get on FanDuel and MGM Sports and
making 20 bucks FanDuel is not about
fans dueling it's about you losing your
fanduel's making bank that's serious
money it's all off of you because they
understand statistics hello
probability probability of a win and and
you don't beat the odds after you play a
while
you occasionally do and that's what
keeps the fools coming back just like my
golf game there you go